porque hoy tenemos un gobierno del
pueblo para el pueblo el 1 de junio de
2019 tras juramentar como presidente
nadie buque le hizo una promesa a
elsalvador construir el país que
queremos menos de un año después en
febrero de 2020 buque le entró con los
militares a la asamblea legislativa y
amenazó con disolver la si no aprobaban
el presupuesto para su plan de seguridad
pues estos delincuentes de la asamblea
legislativa
ni siquiera
[Música]
una acción que la asamblea calificó de
golpe de estado desde entonces el
presidente se ha burlado de aquellos que
lo acusan de autoritario hasta llegar a
denominarse como el dictador de el
salvador en twitter en lo económico se
ha presentado como transgresor al
convertir a su país en el primero en
aceptar el bitcoin como moneda de curso
legal
bitcoin obligó tender en el salvador
algo que no gustó a todos debido a que
la volatilidad de la moneda puede
contribuir al endeudamiento del país
aunque en estos momentos la campaña del
presidente es la que denomina como
guerra contra las pandillas después de
acumular 87 asesinatos en dos días en
marzo bukele decretó un estado de
excepción
tenemos 58 letras durmiendo en el suelo
asignados con los tiempos de comida y en
condiciones que estoy seguro que ninguno
de los pandilleros que están afuera
desde entonces muchos han acusado al
gobierno por cientos de detenciones
ilegales por violaciones de los derechos
humanos y por restringir la libertad de
prensa acciones que aunque le funcionan
nacionalmente con el 91 por ciento de
aceptación según el último sondeo han
hecho que los gobiernos internacionales
como eeuu lo miren con recelo